les faits remontent à 2009
trois pompiers de la brigade des
sapeurs-pompiers de paris sur la
vingtaine impliqué avait été mise en
examen pour viols sur mineurs en juillet
le juge a finalement décidé de
requalifier les faits en atteinte
sexuelle
c'est cette requalification que
plusieurs collectifs féministes ont
dénoncé jeudi 24 septembre devant la
cour d'appel de versailles
tout comme la relaxe des dix sept autres
pompiers ils sont venus également
soutenir julie la victime et corinne sa
mère on attend bien évidemment que les
viols soient reconnus comme des viols
comme des crimes
c'est le combat de julie c'est de faire
reconnaître ce qu'elle a subi
qui un préjudice énorme aujourd'hui elle
est extrêmement fragile elle était déjà
avant et ses pompiers le savait pendant
l'audience le procureur a annoncé qu'il
allait plaider pour le maintien de la
requalification en atteinte sexuelle ce
qui a provoqué la colère des militantes
féministes dont une partie a pénétré
dans l'enceinte de la cour d'appel
elles en sont ressortis quelques minutes
plus tard à la demande de la mère de
julie qui a accepté de s'exprimer à la
fin de l'audience
on est épuisés ce qu'on est restés
dehors c'était un peu frustrant mais
j'ai confiance dans nos avocats nantes
oui nous on dit
j'ai un espoir parce que
toutes les fables la juge est nouvelle
sur sur versailles
j'espère que enfin le dossier va être vu
pour ce qu'il est et non pas parce que
ce sont des pompiers parce que tout
temps des militaires voilà
justice doit être rendue avant la
décision définitive sur cette
qualification sera rendu le 12 novembre
prochain